nearly 700,000 people filed for
unemployment last week more unemployment
claims than we saw at the peak of the
2009 recession we will examine the
promising signs for a cure to
coronavirus and perhaps more importantly
the promising signs the President Trump
is ready to free us from the
dictatorship of public health experts
then mainstream media journalists
humiliate themselves because today is a
day ending in Y and the New York City
government publishes a helpful guide on
how to have sanitary group sodomy during
the pandemic all that and more on
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
all right we've got a lot of updates
here for the coronavirus and I can't
wait to show you the New York City
pandemic sex guide which is a real thing
which we will really get to this is this
is what the dictatorship of expertise
gets us first what are the updates tax
filing deadline has been moved this is a
very good sign it's going to be moved to
July 15th so if you haven't done your
taxes yet you know good you get a little
bit more time some other big moves that
President Trump announced on Friday the
US border with Mexico will be closed to
non-essential travel president Trump has
been trying to get this for three and a
half years and it took a global pandemic
for it to work but that that is done the
US border with Canada will be closed to
non-essential travel perhaps more
important than closing the border with
Mexico since there were all those
Canadian socialists up there another
important update President Trump has
invoked the defense production Act this
is a Korean War era law
began in 1950 and this is a way to turn
American industry to government ends so
for instance if you need to start
producing a lot more ventilators the
government can work with private
industry to do that it sounds a lot more
monumental than it is and it sounds like
we're basically gearing up for World War
two again I guess in a certain way we
are but actually the defense production
act has been invoked many times it was
invoked by Barack Obama during his
administration it's been invoked
something like 20 times since 1950
so not earth-shattering stuff but you
know everyone's so on edge during the
pandemic that anytime they hear
something like that they think that
we're going to all that war or something
a student loan payments have been
suspended for 60 days so if you've got
your student loans that you owe on
you're certainly not in school right now
so it seems perfectly fitting that you
don't have to make payments on those
student loans and no one's got any money
coming in anyway so if you've already
graduated good that you don't have to
make payments on those either and the
Indiana primary election has been pushed
back to June this is part of a trend
that we saw starting in Ohio when
Governor Mike DeWine decided he was
going to cancel the primary for
coronavirus a judge told him he couldn't
do
that he said who cares about the judge
and just closed the polling stations so
it's not just Ohio anymore it's
happening in Indiana this is going to
seriously affect the 2020 race it's it's
going to affect all the way up until the
Democratic convention and then it's
probably going to have effects on the
general election so if you thought that
the whining about it being an unfair
election in 2016 was bad just wait until
we get to November of 2020 and then the
big update on the numbers we now have
451 deaths from coronavirus in the
United States now this all began in late
January so you know obviously for 251
deaths very sad for each of the 451
people and their families for all of us
but it's not a hundred thousand people
it's it's maybe not as bad as some
people were expecting that however has
not stopped the public health experts
from telling us really we're still on
the brink of civilizational collapse
that's why we all need to stay locked up
in our homes and not go anywhere this
from dr. Marty Meharry at public health
expert from Johns Hopkins University who
is insistent that we keep up the
hysteria because if not hundreds of
thousands of people are going to die
some of America still isn't denial that
we even have a problem and you know we
live in a very opinionated country but
this is not fantasy football here these
are facts and this is data and what's
happening in Italy will happen in the
United States they had 793 deaths in the
last 24 hours I saw your interview with
dr. Friedman just now I don't think he
answered your question about how many
cases word we're gonna have here we're
gonna have hundreds of thousands of
deaths and we're gonna have millions of
people with the infection that's based
on the data of Italy extrapolated to our
population what they're experiencing now
is over 4,000 Americans dying per day
when we get to their point in the
infection okay this guy is seriously
misrepresenting the facts what he's
doing has become typical of the
mainstream media and the so-called
experts you know the
we are we are right now basing our
national politics on the apparently
sacrosanct advice of public health
experts rather than dealing with
politics as they are which is where we
discuss issues that are often internal
questions and try to persuade our fellow
citizens we've put all of that aside
that entire American political tradition
aside for the moment and now we're just
doing whatever these public health
experts tell us but are they telling us
the truth I mean the first thing if
you're watching that clip of Meharry the
first thing that's so strange
is looking at on screen you've got the
host then you've got Karl Rove as the
Republican voice then you've got Donna
Brazile the former head of the
Democratic National Committee as the
left-wing voice and then you've got the
public health expert as another as
another left-wing voice but he's
supposedly objective and merely
scientific if you look at Donna Brazile
the whole time he's talking about how
you know hundred thousand people are
gonna die it's gonna be mass chaos
there's gonna be mass death everyone on
screen is very serious about it except
for Donna Brazile who is like smiling
and nodding and it looks really weird
it's the weirdest creepiest reaction
imaginable and if you look maybe she's
just a strange person but if you want to
try to look into that and find out the
political implications of it it would
seem that the political implications are
that the left I'm not saying the left
are cheering on deaths I'm saying the
left is cheering on the alarmism because
the alarmism allows them to get more of
their public policy priorities through
you saw the other day a Rob Reiner meat
head from all in the family famously far
leftist guy said enough of this
state-by-state lockdown we did in a
national lockdown now just kind of funny
because meathead says that he hates
Donald Trump and yet he wants to give
Donald Trump so much more power because
really what the left wants to do the
thing the Left loves about the
coronavirus epidemic is obviously not
the sickness what it loves though is the
power that is going to the government
right now and the total stopping of
politics there is no politics during the
epidemic it's just a tyrannical group of
public
health experts tell us what to do maybe
for our own good doesn't change the fact
that they are determining how our
government is running that's the first
part that's pretty weird about this the
second part that's weird is that he's
completely misrepresenting the facts in
the United States and in Italy we'll get
to that in a second first I got to thank
our friends over at liquid IV this is
certainly not the time to let your body
get dehydrated okay you need to stay
healthy and what makes liquid IV so
effective cellular transport technology
we're ctt the optimal ratio of glucose
sodium and potassium delivers water and
nutrients into the bloodstream right
it's the perfect balance to help you
hydrate quickly and more effectively
than just water alone one stick of
liquid IV in 16 ounces of water can give
you as much hydration as two or three
bottles of plain water so what does that
mean it means if you're going through
tough workouts okay it helps prevent
muscle fatigue and it promotes healthy
post-workout recovery now me maybe I
don't work out that much but if you go
and have a nice long night out or maybe
you're just stuck in your apartment
having a couple adult beverages if you
have your liquid IV at least in my
experience it makes you feel a lot
better the next morning get 25% off when
you go to liquid IV com use code Knowles
Cantu wles at checkout 25% off anything
you order on liquid IVs website go to
liquid IV comm and enter promo code
Knolls to save 25% get better hydration
and energy liquid IV dot-com promo code
Knowles don't wait
start fueling your adventures today so
this guy Marty Meharry who was actually
on Fox oh he wasn't
wasn't even on an outright left-wing
News Channel still though passing along
this sort of alarmism that hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of people are
gonna die ASAP if we don't do something
maybe I don't know I'm not a public
health expert but I do have reason to
believe that he's misrepresenting the
facts so according to Meharry Italy is
the exact preview of what's going to
happen in the United States and the
reason we're believing with Kerry is
because he's an expert from Johns
Hopkins what's strange though is
according to data from Johns Hopkins the
death rate in Italy isn't anything like
the death rate in the United States
right now the death rate
7.9 four percent from coronavirus but
the death rate in the United States is
only one point six eight percent now
they might say well that number is gonna
rise and rise and rise as the United
States gets closer to the stage where
Italy is they'll say that Italy is 11
days ahead in terms of the pandemic than
we are is Italy got it so much sooner
but that doesn't seem to be true if you
if you even track Italy in the United
States
day by day we did it last week I think
was last Wednesday or Thursday if you
looked at where the United States was in
terms of death count compared to where
the United States is compared to where
Italy was 11 days prior Italy had 200
deaths the United States had 100 deaths
even though the United States is five
and a half times larger than Italy so
even if they were the equal populations
we still had many fewer deaths and then
you look at how much larger our
population sizes and you see that that
rate is significantly lower so why are
the Italian number is so high what is it
about Italy well there's some good
reason to believe that Italy is simply a
different country than the United States
I mean not not just in terms of the
literal question they are literally
different countries but in terms of the
national makeup so the Journal of the
American Medical Association JAMA shows
that 40% of infections and 87% of deaths
in Italy have been in patients over 70
years old yeah this tracks with what
we've been hearing the whole time I mean
even if you just look sort of
superficially you realize Italy has the
oldest population in Europe the second
oldest population in the world they all
greet each other by kissing and they're
all smokers right and they don't have a
particularly functioning government and
so it's just a little bit different than
the United States I mean there was one
story I kid you not it came out out of
Florence that the mayor of Florence
various politicians there in the early
days of the coronavirus endorsed a hug a
Chinese person campaign hug a Chinese
person so that it could be shown that
Italians are not racist we are now told
we're not even allowed to hug our
spouses we're not
to hug our family members for the risk
of the the virus spreading but Italy
early on was willing to risk that
entirely to show how not racist they are
probably not the wisest public policy
move according to JAMA the majority of
people in this group were seriously
being affected by the corona virus in
Italy are likely to need critical
hospital care including 80 percent of 80
somethings which is putting a ton of
stress on the Italian healthcare system
but there is an expert there another
expert who's on the other side like
Western professor rich Hardy who says
that actually the reason isn't just from
the age groups and the way the hospitals
are run actually it's a reporting issue
so he says quote the way in which we
code deaths in our country is very
generous in the sense that all the
people who die in hospitals with the
coronavirus are deemed to be dying of
the corona virus that means if you go in
and you're you've got corona virus right
so you're 84 years old
you've got corona virus you were
admitted to the hospital also you've got
stage 4 pancreatic cancer also you've
got pneumonia also you had a stroke last
week if you are admitted to the hospital
with corona virus and you die there then
it will be recorded in Italy as you have
died from corona virus but that's very
confusing because there's a good chance
that person would have died a week later
anyway whether they had corona virus or
not so how do you track it we have this
tracking problem in America too although
I think I actually have the solution and
it's going to put a lot of left-wingers
in a bad position when they try to
extrapolate the last two weeks and make
it into a national power grab policy
we'll get to that in a second first I
gotta thank our friends over at LifeLock
so it's tax season
luckily the deadline was extended I'm
sure you were sending a lot of
information around and you probably will
be now for the next few months during
tax season your name your social
security number lots of valuable
information about yourself is emailed
around a lot more than usual
criminals can steal information from
your devices and sell it on the dark web
or they can use it to commit identity
theft or they can do both
to help prevent this you need a Lifeloc
the number one most recognized brand in
identity theft protection lifelike
monitors for uses of your personal info
alerts you to possible suspicious
activity and if you become a victim of
identity theft a dedicated identity
identity restoration specialist will
work to fix it I really trust these guys
join now and save up to 25% off your
first year just go to LifeLock comm
slash knowles scana wles an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure
that is life lock calm slash Knowles
Canada wles for 25 percent off so you've
got this big recording issue in Italy
there was one analysis of this showed
that you you might be able if you if you
got rid of the recording issue you just
looked at people who died directly
immediately of the coronavirus primarily
of the coronavirus you could bring down
their death numbers by something like an
order of magnitude but it depends on how
you look at it so we have this in the
united states - a big scare example came
out last week here in my own city of los
angeles we'd been hearing 80 year olds
died of coronavirus seventy five year
olds maybe but people who are young do
not until last week we heard of a 34
year old guy in LA who died from the
corona virus I think he had just gone to
Disneyland so he's in a very crowded
place mean it even scarier that is a
scary headline especially if you are
someone about my age what they buried in
the article though is that this guy had
underlying health conditions and some
pretty serious ones he had a lifelong
history of asthma of frequent bronchitis
and then as recently as 3-4 years ago he
had testicular cancer so he was treated
for cancer this is no easy treatment and
then he got coronavirus those details
are relevant here because something
tells me that the health of somebody who
doesn't have those chronic conditions
who hasn't recently been treated for
cancer is quite different than somebody
who has so how do you figure out who is
right there are two groups of people
right now as I see it they're the people
who say that shutting down the world
economy pausing
everybody locking everyone in their
apartments is perfectly reasonable and
there should be no end in sight and
really if anything we under reacted so
the Democratic governor of New York some
doubt summed up this view Andy Cuomo and
equal moe is now all the left-wing
governors are trying to one-up each
other so you know governor Newsom in
California does something and equal moe
wants to do more than that or the local
mayor's Eric Garcetti in LA does
something because the leftist mayor of
San Francisco does something so then the
governor wants to do it right there all
one-upping each other
Andy Cuomo said of his policy to more or
less lock down the state he said if
everything we do
saves just one life I'll be happy now
how you can argue with that sentiment
you don't care about human life if
that's the that's the conclusion if you
don't want to do everything that Andy
Cuomo is done then you don't care about
human life now of course this policy is
absurd none of us actually believe it's
true 90 people 100 and actually the
numbers closer to 100 102 people die on
average in car accidents every single
day so we should ban cars right is there
we wouldn't just be saving one life we'd
be saving 102 lives a day 102 people who
would go home to their families every
day if we got rid of automobiles so do
you not support getting rid of
automobiles what you don't care about
human life
you're not as wonderful and moral a
person as andy Cuomo no of course not
that's not that's not the takeaway from
that I mean even just consider what Andy
poem was saying he's saying if we stop
the global economy and that saves one
life from the coronavirus it was worth
it how many lives are gonna be ended
because we stopped the global economy I
mean just forget about how the supply
chain is going to affect people forget
about how all of the confusion is going
to affect people's lives just consider
everyone losing their jobs record number
of people have applied for unemployment
we'll get to that in a second
when people lose their jobs
suicide ticks up
personally no of two people who have
killed themselves because of two people
who have tried to kill themselves one
person who succeeded because of this
shut down coinciding with this shutdown
is weren't you don't need to send
sympathy or anything and these were not
like close friends of mine but these are
stories that I've heard of from friends
of mine so I'm only one one degree
removed from them
how many more stories are there like
that okay if just me just I have heard
of two people doing this one of whom
succeeded at it what's going on around
the country already you know and let's
say one person lives from coronavirus
but then one person kills himself
because he lost his job if we're taking
a purely utilitarian calculus here
probably wasn't the smartest thing to do
right that's what Andy quote that's andy
poem was calculus here that's one group
of people and i think what they're
saying is indefensible but it's
emotionally very compelling the other
group of people think maybe it wasn't
the greatest idea to shut down the
global economy maybe it was maybe it
wasn't we just don't know that's the
group of the skeptics so there's the
people who say grind everything to a
halt please install doctor foul chi as
our world ruler who will tell us
everything to do a wise and Noble
Emperor and there's the other group that
says maybe we need to balance different
things maybe we shouldn't just focus
with 100 percent myopia on the
coronavirus this is what is meant by the
dictatorship of public health experts
there's a leftist idea that the people
we should put in charge or the experts
and this has been the leftist idea for
hundreds of years now if you're the
public health expert then you've got to
run all of public health policy if
you're the environmentalist expert
you've got to run all environmental
policy now the trouble is all these
different areas of policy affect one
another if you're the economic expert
you got to run all of economic policy
they all affect one another and so
there's a conservative idea which is
that of course we
listen to the opinion of experts of
course we should look at the data look
at science but the experts are actually
the last people we should put in charge
because the the experts by definition
their whole career has been putting on
blinders
so all they can see is their one field
of expertise but actually in governance
in politics you need to take off the
blinders you need to have generalists in
charge so that they can not miss the
forest for the trees that group of
people who are say maybe the skeptics or
who are trying to balance other
priorities here as well I certainly
count myself in that group I suspect
most of you count yourselves in that
group how do we figure out who's right I
have a solution but first I've got to
thank our friends over at M sleep you
haven't trouble falling asleep these
days I suspect maybe you are maybe you
got some worries on your mind I know
just about everybody has worries on
their mind these days if you've tried
everything from pills to pillows with
little success it's time for you to try
AB AB sleep is a wearable solution that
fits over the forehead and gently and
precisely cools the forehead to reduce
those racing thoughts allowing people
who suffer from sleeplessness to drift
more comfortably into a deeper more
restorative sleep the minds normal way
of dealing with stress and challenges is
to be on guards to be vigilant it's like
when you're old old tents at night you
can't fall asleep that's the reverse of
what is needed for a restful night's
sleep but brain imaging studies followed
by 3,800 nights of clinical studies by
renowned sleep researchers revealed a
revolutionary new way to sleep and that
is M I highly recommend you try this I
have slept with it it is unbelievable is
an unbelievable solution I've never seen
anything like it
it really does cool your mind cool your
racing thoughts you've got to check it
out have the energy to do the things you
love again by getting the sleep you need
ABS natural solution has no morning
side-effects allows you to get back to
your peak performance our listeners can
now try em for free for 60 nights to
confirm it's the solution you've been
looking for go to try F calm slash
Knowles TR ye be be calm / Knowles try
AB calm / Knowles order today
to get the sleep you need and deserve
how do we figure out who is right here
you can't do it by simply counting
deaths from coronavirus you can't do it
by the counterfactual either you can't
say well had we not done these measures
then the numbers would have been the
same right because all we know is the
effect of what we actually did all right
what you'll hear from the power grab
people at the end of all of this even if
we lock down the whole country and we
get to the end of it we crash the global
economy and let's say only 50,000 people
die you know something comparable to a
flu epidemic what they will say is we
had to do what we did because if not 10
gazillion people would have died and you
would have no way of proving that wrong
except this one the way to count the
effectiveness of these policies is to
first factor in all the people who would
have died anyway even without
coronavirus this is this would fix the
recording problem in Italy so every
single day about 7,500 people die in the
United States of heart disease car
accidents all sorts of ailments people
die I know that we forget this in our
materialistic culture but people do die
so 7,500 people die per day what we now
need to do and then that takes in
seasonal flu that takes in all other
sorts of epidemics what we need to do to
figure out the true death toll from
coronavirus both in the United States in
Italy elsewhere is simply figure out how
many more people died per day now it by
the way you can't take it just day by
day because that's an average so you
have to look at exactly how many people
died different seasons of the year when
this is all over when you're calculating
the death toll we need to take that
number into account it also will allow
us to compare it across countries is our
response like Italy you know that expert
who went on TV Meharry at the top of the
show he seems to think that we're
exactly like Italy some people want to
point out that actually our response has
been quite different from Italy we don't
have hugging campaigns we have social
distancing campaigns here for one
example we
and the border much earlier if the
number is massive of extra deaths from
coronavirus here and elsewhere in the
world we will know that we did the right
thing if the number is not massive if
the number is more comparable to say a
flu epidemic we will know that we
perhaps overreacted we will be able to
hold to account people who stoked the
hysteria now luckily President Trump
gets it the left doesn't get it the left
is going bonkers and they're posting a
lot of weird videos and weird sex guides
around the internet which we will get to
but president Trump is showing evidence
that he really does get it me smacking
down the mainstream media all the while
to show it we'll get to that in a second
first I got to thank our friends over at
over at the Daily wire website actually
not not even our friends at a regular
sponsor I got to thank our members and
our all-access members if you haven't
had a chance to see some of our new
content called all access live you
should head over to Daley wire.com and
check it out a Jeremy and Ben kicked
this off last week and then we all did
live streams each day over daily wire
comm we're going to continue that all
this week at 8 p.m. eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific this is a very relaxed show okay
this is not one of our highly produced
totally organized news shows this is
just a way to hang out because that's
all we're doing these days in our
quarantine the show is intended for our
all-access members but during this
national emergency and time of isolation
we've opened it up to all of our members
and in doing so we've we've accelerated
the launch a little bit so please let us
know what you think of that if you're
around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. pacific
tonight join us over on the all-access
live show daily wire.com
head on over there subscribe you will
not regret it
we'll be right back with a lot more
President Trump gets it he gets this
fear he gets why we need to crack the
dictatorship of experts he's taking it
seriously just good we want him to do
that he's also cracking jokes about
tyrannical government who's doing a
press conference I believe this was on
Friday and he's standing doctor foul Qi
and Mike Pence and Mike Pompeo are
behind him and he cracks a joke about
how he's got to get Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo back to the State Department
or as some people call it the deep State
Department you know what I'd like to do
I'd like to him to go back to the State
Department or as they call it the deep
State Department you don't mind I'd like
to have him go back and do his job so
does anybody have any question so the
greatest part of this exchange is first
of all Trump is not allowing this
pandemic to cower him it's not is not
allowing it to force him into retreat
and to defer simply to the the
dictatorship of experts but when you
look at the chief expert in the country
dr. fowey who's been doing a very good
job the minute that Trump says the deep
State Department you see the smirk just
tick up on fat cheese face and you can
see he's just trying to suppress a laugh
so his mouth is all sort of contorting
and he just puts his head down you know
he's like scratching his forehead so
that he can hide his smile
he's obviously getting a kick out of it
really gives me even more confidence
that the guy knows what he's doing that
he can crack a laugh about the the
bureaucracy and our federal government
that the next aspect of Trump's response
that is really giving me confidence is a
tweet he sent out last night all caps
that's how you know that a Trump tweet
is really serious he tweets that quote
we cannot let the Cure be worse than the
problem itself at the end of the 15 day
period we will make a decision as to
which way we want to go exclamation
point love this my man that's exactly
what you need to say right now because
right now we're in quarantine we've been
in quarantine for what like seven days
or so and the
that's making the market stank the thing
that's making people freak out is we
don't know when the end is going to be
this is gonna drag on for two weeks two
months 18 months I don't know we gotta
wait for the experts to tell us how to
live our lives I guess whatever they say
that's what we're gonna do give up our
liberties don't go to Mass they closed
churches everywhere that's cool that's
fine you take all of our freedoms take
everything that we want to do
indefinitely I don't think so Americans
are willing to have solidarity come
together help each other out so even
suspend some of our rights for a limited
period of time we need to know when that
comes to an end and this 15-day period
was what they talked about at the
beginning 15 days to stop the virus or
to slow down the spread of the virus
cool I'll be a sport for 15 days won't
be a spot sport for 15 months won't be a
sport for 15 years
need an end date and so that end date
now it looks like it'd be about March
30th I really hope that President Trump
sticks to this and barring some
seriously evidenced catastrophe on the
horizon if we don't extend it I want him
to end it at 15 days there were almost
six hundred ninety four thousand new
unemployment claims between last Monday
and last Wednesday that blows the 2009
recession out of the water it actually
blew past the 2009 recession how much
longer we gonna let that go on are we
gonna let the unemployment rate get up
to 30% maybe maybe starting to go there
are we gonna let it stay there for
months and months crash the economy
probably not a great idea there were
unintended effects of that that the our
public health experts simply cannot
factor in the media are furious at Trump
for trying to remind people that this is
going to end quickly for trying to find
a quick solution to this they're furious
at Trump because he attacked a reporter
over this exact question he called an
NBC journalist a terrible reporter for
asking Trump what he would say to
Americans who were scared that's the
narrative the narrative the mainstream
media is putting out for you right now
is that a reporter asked a perfectly
legitimate question mr.
president what do you say to Americans
who were scared and Trump unhinged crazy
up against a wall couldn't give an
answer to this question it was such a
horrible moment for Trump the exchange
came after President Trump announced the
possibility of a breakthrough regarding
a cure to coronavirus a drug called
chloroquine and some people would add to
it hydroxy hydroxychloroquine so
chloroquine or hydroxychloroquine now
this is a common malaria drug it's also
a drug used for strong arthritis okay
this is drug he goes on to describe it I
love the way he to chloroquine some
people look some people might say
hydroxychloroquine okay what I'm take
any either name but it treats malaria
treats arthritis and this may have an
application to coronavirus hey great
news there should be applause from the
press in that room right how exciting
that's not what happened now here is the
very selectively edited clip that is
going around the internet now and being
pushed by the mainstream media and all
the blue check marks to make Trump look
like he's throwing a temper tantrum
we're scared though I guess nearly 200
dead 14,000 you're sick millions as you
witness who are scared right now what
you say to Americans we're watching you
right now you're scared I say that
you're a terrible reporter that's what I
say it's a very nasty question and I
think it's a very bad signal that you're
putting out to the American people the
American people are looking for answers
and they're looking for hope and you're
doing sensationalism and the same with
NBC and Comcast I don't quote I don't
call it Comcast I call it Comcast let me
just ask whom you work let me just say
something that's really bad reporting
and you want to get back to report a
good set of sensationalism let's see if
it works it might and it might not I
happen to feel good about it but who
knows I've been right a lot all right
Trump very forcefully as
right a lot but the response from most
people when they see that clip as they
say it was a totally fair question it
was a totally outrageous response look
he was just asking what do you say to
Americans who were scared Trump can't
answer that one that softball right
wrong because that was Alexander's
follow up to the first extraordinarily
biased series of questions here's the
real clip dr. pouchy said there is no
magic drug for coronavirus right now
which you would agree I guess on this
issue I think we only disability sorry
maybe and maybe not maybe there is maybe
there isn't we have to see we're gonna
is it possible that your impulse to put
a positive spin on things maybe giving
Americans a false sense right now I
don't think so I think that I think it's
good you know and not get a pretty look
it may work and it may not work and I
agree with the doctor what he said may
work may not work I feel good about it
that's all it is just a feeling you know
I'm smart guy I feel good about it and
we're gonna see you're gonna see soon
enough
that's the prelude to Trump going off on
the reporter then he goes yeah but what
do you know what do you say to Americans
were scared because you're a terrible
reporter you keep interrupting me you
keep asking these condescending
questions I mean from the very beginning
Peter Alexander from NBC his question is
hey there's no magic drug it's not mad
how kind of sending that weird magic hey
mr. president what do you think look the
way that you always put a positive spin
on things you know how you exaggerate
and lie you liar yeah well what do you
think don't you think it's giving
Americans a false sense of hope and
really they're all gonna die aren't they
they're all gonna die tell them they're
all gonna die and then Trump starts to
answer and Peter Alexander keeps peeking
keeps interrupting him as he's answering
frankly I think Trump held his temper
very well until the very end he goes hey
buster
you're a terrible reporter you're a hack
your outlet is a hack outlet and you're
not helping the situation here you're
not reporting the news first of all and
you're scaring people and you're doing
sensationalism and you're
trying to make this situation worse
absolutely right but then it gets even
better the most outrageous part of all
of this don't forget this was in
response to Trump saying there's this
drug called chloroquine which might help
it's showing some promise Media pile on
him Peter Alexander this is false hope
Andy Cuomo Democratic governor of New
York gives almost the exact same press
conference touting in almost the exact
same terms the exact same drug here is
we're also implementing the trial drug
we have secured 70,000 hydro chloroquine
10,000 zithromax from the federal
government I want to thank the FDA for
moving very expeditiously to get us this
supply okay same that's basically the
same exact news conference that Trump
gave tone is always a little bit
different but the substance of it
identical when Trump does it it's a
false sense of hope what happens when
Andy Cuomo does it brian Stelter CNN
take it away it's been a remarkable show
of leadership by Governor Cuomo in
recent days he's providing hope but not
false hope not fall so that's what Trump
pedals when Trump is using the exact
same words
Andy Cuomo is using that's false hope
when Andy Cuomo does it that's real hope
not false hope this is CNN facts first
mainstream media and then cuz look maybe
you say okay look they're both left-wing
outlets NBC and CNN maybe they just had
a different take on this know John King
on CNN goes on CNN and explains in
coarse vulgar language why president
Trump's reaction to Peter Alexander was
totally outrage as it was BS I sat in
that room for just shy of 10 years it
was a perfectly valid question and what
the president did to Peter Alexander is
reprehensible the American people are
looking for answers they do want hope
they do want support mr. president that
was a very fair question our Caitlin
Collins is in the briefing room right
now she was there for that contentious
briefing Caitlin this is a trump
trademark this is a trump trade market
striking that this came is that this
forgive me bull an attack on fake news
came just moments after the Secretary of
State said the American people need to
be careful about where they get their
information and go to sources they can
trust I get there are times
disagreements there are at times
contention between politicians and
reporters that was a 100% legitimate
question with no hype no shade no biased
he just wanted to attack no no bias no
shade no - no not at all but a by the
way went and that was BS that was
outrageous that was terrible when Trump
did it but Andy Cuomo
Wow not giving anyone false hope thank
good I mean no reporter would ever ever
even dared ask him the question that
they asked Trump of course not he's
peddling true hope not
false hope what a clown what a total
clown that guy is first of all do you
remember when journalists didn't have to
use four-letter words on national
television in their news reports well I
guess I'd have to remember all the way
back to when there were actual
journalists and reporters out there and
not leftist hacks just taking any
potshot they can at the president even
when it swings back and humiliates
themselves the New York City government
speaking of humiliation the New York
City government has published a guide to
having sex during a pandemic you think
the vulgar language used by John King on
CNN was bad just wait until you hear the
the actual public health recommendations
from the New York City government I am
not exaggerating when I tell you this
document sex and coronavirus disease
2019 is the filthiest document I have
read in quite some time I just give you
the highlights and if you have young
children they cover their ears for the
next two minutes all New Yorkers should
stay home and minimize contact with
others to reduce the spread of kovat 19
but can you have sex here are some tips
for how to enjoy sex and to avoid
spreading kovat 19 enjoy alright that's
kind of weird that's not usually like
clinical public public health language
but that's fine we still have a lot to
learn about
in nineteen and sex have sex with people
close to you you are your safest sex
partner masturbation will not spread
kovat 19 especially if you wash your
hands and any sex toys with soap and
water for at least 20 seconds before and
after sex you are your safest I guess it
is sex with someone I love but I don't
this doesn't seem like the kind of
advice you should be getting from your
government
the next safest sex partner is someone
you live with having close contact
including sex with only a small circle
of people helps prevent spreading kovat
19 you know not exactly the same sort of
advice we used to hear from our our
leaders on sex used to or maybe our
parents and say you know find a girl you
love get married live happily ever after
now they're saying have sex with a small
circle of people not a large circle that
would be wrong and immoral but a small
circle of people that's that's fine if
you usually you should avoid close
contact including sex with anyone
outside your household now this raises a
lot of creepy questions that I don't
want to get into if you usually meet
your sex partners online or make a
living by having sex consider taking a
break from in-person dates video dates
sexting or chat rooms may be options for
you
Mayor Bill DeBlasio telling us to sext
that's why we elected him I guess now it
gets really this is the part really
cover cover up the ears take care during
sex kissing can easily Pasco vid 19
kissing anyone who is not part of your
small circle of close contacts [ __ ]
mouth on anus might spread co-ed 19
virus and feces may enter your mouth
this is published by the New York City
government on how to handle the pandemic
condoms and dental dams can reduce
contact with saliva or feces especially
during world or anal sex good always
wanted anal sex tips from my mayor
washing up before and after sex is now
more important than ever wash hands
often with soap and water for at least
20 seconds interesting stapling job they
did here
it's been interesting wash sex toys with
soap and warm water
thanks again mayor de Blasio disinfect
keyboards and touchscreens that you
share with others for video chat for
watching pornography or for anything
else forget about the debate we've been
having on the right which is should city
governments regulate pornography or even
ban pornography or you know we we had
obscenity laws in this country we still
do actually all over the place but
they're rarely if ever enforced these
days now you've got your city government
encouraging to watch pornography
encouraging you on how to watch
pornography skip sex if your partner is
not feeling well if you or a partner may
have kovat 19 avoid sex and especially
kissing so maybe you're gonna have sex
definitely don't kiss your sex partner
and prevent HIV or other sexually
transmitted infections and unplanned
pregnancy by the way kind of an
interesting thing we've shut down
virtually every institution in this
country because of the the corona virus
and yet abortion clinics remain open
apparently that's an essential service
and same shows you the priorities of the
the experts maybe show some ulterior
motives shows us that maybe this is not
just a public health dictatorship that
we're living in it might be something of
a political dictatorship because when
when questions of health become public
health and use the arm of government to
enforce their dictates all of a sudden
we're talking about a political question
and unless you want to live in a world
that is that issues more and more
guidebooks like the New York City sex
guide unless you want to live in a world
in which government bureaucrats are
invading the most personal and perverted
aspects of your life and encouraging
those perversions by the way then we're
probably going to want to return to
normal sooner rather than later we will
listen to the public health experts as
they guide us on that way but ultimately
we will have to make the decision
our selves that's our show we got a
whole lot more to get to we'll have to
do it tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stevens assistant director Havel
without ski editor and associate
producer Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen